welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Robert harms the Henry J Heinz
professor of history and African Studies
at Yale professor harms is the author of
the diligent voyage through the worlds
of the slave trade which is won numerous
prestigious awards he has also written
two books on the history of Equatorial
Africa river of wealth river of sorrow
the central ziyarah basin in the era of
the slave and ivory trade and games
against nature an echo cultural history
of the new-new of equatorial africa
today we'll talk with professor harms
about his newest endeavor a book called
the imperialists and the slave trader
conflict collaboration and the making of
colonialism in Equatorial Africa 1874 to
1905 welcome professor harms glad to be
here so what is the premise of the
imperialists and the slave trader well
the book is set during the Scramble for
Africa in the late 19th century and
that's a time when all the major powers
of Europe were more or less tripping
over each other to try to lay claim to
the resources and territories of Africa
and the Scramble for Africa has
previously been looked at almost always
at a macro level where you look at the
strategies of the great powers and
empires and plots of empire building and
competition among the European powers
and I want to reverse it and look at it
at a micro level focusing on people who
were on the ground in Africa and the
premise is that often in this early
period events in Africa itself on the
ground were driving the process and the
European powers would make decisions
that would follow in the wake of the
African events themselves okay so tell
us what the book is about well the book
focuses on the Congo River Basin which
is Equatorial Africa and in 1875 the
whole Congo River Basin was entirely
unknown territory to the Europeans they
didn't even know
where the Congo River went 30 years
later by 1905 the whole territory had
been colonized part of it by the
Belgians and part of it by the French
and by 1905 two explosive international
reports came out showing that the
Belgian and French congos were the most
heavily and massively and brutally
exploited parts of all of Africa so the
main narrative then is how did it go
from terra incognita in 1875 to the most
heavily exploited part of africa in 1905
and in order to tell that story I focus
on three characters who were both
explorers and empire abilities on their
own right and the first is Henry Morton
Stanley born in Wales became an American
citizen ended up working for King
Leopold two of Belgian to create the
Congo Free State which later became the
Belgian Congo
the second one was Pierre settling on de
brazza who's an Italian who worked for
the French and he then created French
Equatorial Africa and the third
character is an African an afro Arab
slave trader named Hamid bin Muhammad
but known to everybody as Tipu tip and
he created a large slave and ivory
trading empire in the eastern Congo and
this was a territory that henry morton
stanley and King Leopold heavily coveted
throughout the years of the book and so
the idea of the narrative is that if you
look at the way these three characters
sometimes collaborated with one another
sometimes had bitter fights with one
another and through this pattern of
conflict and collaboration emerged the
earliest structures of colonialism in
Equatorial Africa okay so how did you
come to write the book was the idea born
out of the research you did for the
diligent well my first experience in
Africa was teaching in a high school in
eastern Congo right in the middle of the
territory for Tipu Tibbs Empire once
existed so I've known about Tipu tip for
my whole career and been interested in
him then when I was in graduate school I
did some research on the rubber
atrocities
in the Belgian Congo in the early
colonial period and this book is a way
to put those two interests together
because in a very indirect way that the
exploitation done by Tipu terrible later
on got replaced by the exploitation done
by Stanley's empire that he creates
working for King Leopold and so one can
trace a direct line from the one kind of
exploitation to the other and so that
made the process attractive but there is
actually a connection with the diligent
very indirect which is when the diligent
came out was being reviewed one of the
reviewers said well you know a lot of
scrutiny has been put onto the Atlantic
slave trade and the European slave
traders but he said but no similar
scrutiny has been put to the Arab slave
traders in Equatorial Africa in the 19th
century and he says and he especially
named Tipu tipper said nobody is
scrutinized to protip as much as Robert
harms scrutinized people under diligence
so that's not the reason I'm writing the
book but once it's out I could call up
that reviewer and say see I scrutinized
Tipu tip 2 and I have to say that when I
was reading the book I was fascinated by
that aspect of it because I had never I
was not aware that Africans basically
took advantage of other Africans so I
thought that was very interesting so how
did you do the research for the book
well this is all based on archives and
the good part about the research is that
I get to travel to interesting places
and the the papers relating to tip to
tip are mostly on the island of Zanzibar
off the east coast of Africa and when I
spent the summer before last in Zanzibar
I rented an apartment and the apartment
in in the building that I was renting
was about 20 feet away from the house
the huge mansion the Tipu tip had built
in the 1890s in Zanzibar so that tip for
tip was my neighbor for the whole self
and did you plan it that way or was it
so and I just found out Wow
after I got there
the apartment through email contacts and
when I got there somebody pointed out
that the house right next door was the
one who built by tipper tip so that so
that tipper tips papers are in Zanzibar
now Henry Morton Stanley's papers were
in private hands for most of this
century until recently they were sold by
the Stanley family to the Royal Museum
for Central Africa and Tervuren Belgium
it took them about a dozen years to get
them inventoried but now starting about
three or four years ago they became
available to the public I'll be one of
the first people using the Stanley
papers brazos papers are in Exxon
Provence in southern France and those
papers have been there a long time and
been inventory but it's recently come to
light that some of the most important
especially reports about the early the
later part of his life and surrounding
his death which had been thought to be
lost for years might not be lost at all
and I'll be going back there over
Christmas break to see what I can find
wow that must be very exciting for you
do you have any ideas of what you might
uncover well what I'm looking for is
that I mentioned that in 1905 a report
came out about atrocities in the Belgian
Congo and another report about
atrocities in the French Congo and the
commission that reported on the
atrocities in the French Congo was
headed by brazo
and he died on the show on the way home
from Africa and the whole report that he
was writing and that his fellow
Commission members were writing were all
repressed and then another Commission
was appointed which wrote is sort of a
whitewash type report but all of the
original report notes and drafts were
never found but I ran across a reference
recently to somebody who had actually
seen them in the in the 1970s in a box
in the French archives and so I'm going
to try to see if I could find that box
okay well good luck with that
your book highlights several
underdeveloped themes in the history of
early colonialism talk about some of
them well first of all I'm putting the
events in the context of the
globalization of the late 19th century
when a lot of African products that had
not been seen as all that valuable in
the world market suddenly became seen as
valuable and crucial and two of these
products that affected Equatorial Africa
were ivory and rubber and one connection
to us here in Connecticut is that one of
the major destinations for the ivory
coming out of Equatorial Africa was I've
written Connecticut where the tusks were
made into piano keys and billiard balls
all of which graced the homes of the
rising American bourgeoisie so when
somebody shoots an elephant and takes
the tusks you know it's related to a
form of globalization it's related to a
form of economic development in the
United States and so their worldwide
connections to all of these events a
second theme has to do with the African
Empire builders because most studies of
the Scramble for Africa focus on the
European Empire builders and what
they've forgotten is that as certain
African commodities are becoming more
valuable in the world market there are a
lot of Africans who are jumping into the
game and wanting to build their own
empires and corner the market on those
commodities and Tipu tip was one of
those and that's why I'm making one of
the central characters of the story and
then a third theme has to do with the
the Arab and Swahili slave trade that
brought slaves out of Equatorial Africa
toward Zanzibar and distributed them
around the Indian Ocean and when people
talk about the Scramble for Africa they
often focus on the economic motives of
the Europeans the strategic motives of
the Europeans but what they forget is
that there was a huge anti-slavery
campaign going on in Europe at the time
against the Arab slave trade and that
was the big humanitarian cause of its
decade
the irony is that it was this campaign
against the Arab slave trade in Europe
that helped drum up public opinion in
Europe for colonialism and the fourth
theme finally is just to capture a sense
of the time and the place because when
we look back at that period today it
seemed inevitable that the Europeans
would win out and end up taking over
Africa but for people who were in the
ground at the time it wasn't at all
inevitable and this is a very wide open
period when a penniless adventurer could
become a potentate and everything seemed
wide-open and chaotic and I want to
capture that sense of opportunity and
chaos that existed for the people at the
time okay so are there any historical
lessons that we can perhaps take from
your book and apply them today
well this Africa in the 1870s was a very
different place than it is today and
we're now over a century later but there
is one cautionary tale that comes out of
the book and that that is that the
humanitarians in Europe who were
organizing rallies against the Arab
slave trade in Equatorial Africa ended
up creating the circumstances which
allowed to gain public support for
colonial adventures which ended up
creating a form of colonialism that was
every bit as brutal as the situation
created by the the Arab slave traders
and one example is King Leopold of the
Congo who was Henry one Stanley's boss
at one point he organized a big
international conference to whip up
international support against the Arab
slave trade during that conference he
appoints Tipu tib who was the biggest
Arab slave trader of them all to be his
governor of the eastern Congo and so
what happens is the humanitarians were
extremely sincere but they got
hopelessly outmaneuvered by the cynical
Empire builders okay and what is the
most surprising thing you found in doing
your research well in focusing on my
three character main characters
one thing that came to me is that they
all had very common
like personalities Stanley was born in
in Wales came to America fought on both
sides of the Civil War went to Africa
working for the New York Herald to find
David Livingstone then got hired by King
Leopold of the Belgians to create the
Congo Free State and then he was later a
member of parliament in Britain so he
had a lot of different identities during
his lifetime career brazo was an Italian
who worked for the French and ended up
being buried in Algeria after his death
about three years ago his body was moved
to Brazzaville in the Congo which is the
city of course named after the third
character Tipu tib had Arab Omani Arab
ancestry and yahweh's II African
ancestors and he was sometimes an Arab
or sometimes an African depending on who
was asking so my feeling is that in that
period when everything was wide open and
influx and there were really no states
that could impose any kind of state like
order on things it was these people with
the chameleon-like personalities who
survived okay well it sounds very
fascinating thank you very much for
being with us here today and sharing
some of your work I've joined it for
more information about Professor harms
and his work please visit our website at
Yale edu backslash Macmillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you